Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Quando ero adolescente,
feci una cosa che molti liceali fanno:
provai a leggere Siddharta.
E dico provai, e non lessi,
perché il mio interesse
per quell'animo inquieto
durò giusto lo spazio
della nota introduttiva,
oltretutto scritta
dal traduttore italiano.
Nelle prime righe della nota,
ci si sofferma su una parola
che diventa fondamentale per me
e per la comprensione dell'intero romanzo,
ma in generale per il mio percorso:
“Der Suchende”, una parola tedesca
che significa "Colui che cerca".
Nelle prime righe, il traduttore italiano
designa quegli uomini, con questa parola,
che non si accontentano
della superficie delle cose
ma vogliono, da ogni aspetto
della vita, ragionando,
andare in fondo
per capire meglio loro stessi
e il rapporto che tra loro
e il mondo intercorrono.
Sono parole, e temi,
che quasi la totalità di noi,
quasi sempre nell'adolescenza,
sente come fondamentali.
E forse è per questo
che Siddharta viene ricordato
come uno di quei libri dell'adolescenza,
uno di quelli che citiamo
anche senza averlo letto.
Non che io non l'abbia letto,
ma indubbiamente la prefazione
è la parte che ho preferito.
C'è poi un altro riferimento fondamentale,
ma che, a differenza del rapporto
travagliato con Siddharta,
rischia di relegarmi
ai margini delle statistiche
sui trend topics dell'adolescenza,
ed è la matematica.
Iniziai a preferire i libri
di matematica a tutti gli altri,
con buona pace di Hermann Hesse,
quando scoprii la storia del Nautilus.
Un mollusco, anzi,
il mollusco per antonomasia.
Il Nautilus è uno
dei rarissimi esseri viventi
riuscito a sopravvivere
dai tempi dei dinosauri ad oggi.
E non sopravvisse per delle doti
particolari, ovviamente,
è poco più di una lumaca;
ma per la forma della sua conchiglia
a spirale logaritmica.
Potevamo tranquillamente
darlo per estinto,
ma in realtà lui è
ancora lì, dopo millenni:
potremmo dire "in lockdown", ma sereno.
Se ricordo ancora l'incipit
di un libro che ho finito a stento,
è grazie alla conchiglia
a spirale del Nautilus.
È grazie allo stupore che provai
davanti alla sua conchiglia.
Lo stupore che io provai
è lo stupore di un suchende,
di qualcuno che cerca.
Nel mio caso, in frammenti di formule,
qualche chiave di ingresso
per comprendere più nel dettaglio
il principio unificatore di un equilibrio
che, anche se non sempre
lo vediamo, sappiamo esistere.
Nella vita di tutti i giorni
osserviamo e misuriamo cose.
Il concetto di proporzione è inteso
come corrispondenza di misura
tra due o più elementi
in rapporto reciproco.
Detta in parole più semplici:
una linea di divisione
che separa il sopra dal sotto,
il numeratore dal denominatore.
Non è estraneo a nessuno
dei nostri più quotidiani calcoli;
ma la nostra mente,
quando diciamo "proporzione",
va un po’ oltre.
Attribuisce in maniera automatica
un connotato degli attributi di armonia,
rigenerazione ed equilibrio.
Una cosa "proporzionata"
ci sembra qualcosa che vada oltre
ad una linea di frazione
con un numeratore e un denominatore;
ma in realtà, quando la nostra mente
fa questo collegamento
spontaneo di significante,
si sta riferendo ad una accezione
e ad una eccezione precisa di proporzione.
L'hanno scoperta e riscoperta,
battezzata e ribattezzata:
"Golden section", "golden proportion",
"divine proportion", "sacred cut",
sezione aurea, proporzione aurea.
Ma il valore è sempre 1,618034.
Così ricorrente, in natura,
che gli hanno attribuito, i matematici,
una delle lettere
dell'alfabeto greco, che è ϕ.
Se i numeri, e le astrazioni,
possono essere fastidiose,
o ostili da cogliere,
possiamo fare qualche passo insieme.
Cos'è una proporzione, in generale?
Quattro euro stanno
ad un chilo di castagne
come dieci euro stanno
a due chili e mezzo di castagne.
Niente da dire: 4 diviso 1
è uguale a 10 diviso 2,5.
Seppur nulla tolga al nostro fruttivendolo
di fare un'offerta di questo secondo tipo,
non è una proporzione matematica dire
che quattro euro stanno ad un chilo
come dieci euro stanno
ad un chilo e mezzo di castagne.
Ovvero, quattro diviso uno
non è 10 diviso 1,5.
Ma non tutte le proporzioni corrette,
come la precedente, sono auree.
Non percepiamo l'infinito
dal calcolo di prima.
Proporzione aurea è quella proporzione
tale per cui A diviso B,
ovvero C diviso D,
è uguale a 1,618034,  ovvero ϕ.
Millenni di calcoli, e di osservazioni,
hanno portato a scoprire
nelle distanze la sezione aurea,
più frequente che in tante altre cose.
Millenni di esercizi, infatti,
hanno visto l'uomo capire
qual è il punto preciso, il punto aureo,
in cui dividere in due un segmento.
Si è scoperto che il punto preciso,
in cui dividere in due un segmento,
è quello tale per cui
si rispetta la proporzione
in cui il tutto sta al grande
come il grande sta al piccolo.
L'intero percorso sta alla parte più lunga
come la parte più lunga
sta alla parte più corta.
Scritto in matematichese, abbiamo:
A più B diviso A è uguale ad A diviso B.
Riducendo i termini,
e sostituendo ϕ per semplicità,
risolviamo l'equazione di secondo grado
e otteniamo ϕ: 1,618034.
Tutto chiaro?
(Risate)
Immaginate, allora, lo stupore
che provarono i matematici -
ancor prima di fare questi calcoli,
perché i calcoli vengono dopo -
quando scoprirono
che la distanza delle labbra
di una donna dal suo mento è A
quando la distanza dei suoi occhi
dalla sua bocca è B.
O quando scoprirono che solo
il DNA dell'uomo ha ϕ.
O ϕ lo ritroviamo in tante cose
che ci contraddistinguono.
Ma io torno a pensare
allo stupore dei biologi,
quando scoprirono che l'unico
a essere riuscito a sopravvivere,
dai dinosauri ad oggi,
è una lumaca.
E non sopravvisse
per doti speciali di lumaca
ma per la struttura della sua casa,
a spirale logaritmica,
da non confondere con la chiocciola.
Perché è speciale?
il Nautilus ha costruito,
nel tempo, una casa
che gli permette di vivere
sempre nella stanza più piccola,
e spostarsi nella stanza successiva,
più grande, quando è pronto.
Questo gli permette di avere sempre
il suo baricentro in equilibrio.
L'asse di rotazione resta invariato,
aumenta solo il raggio.
E grazie a questo sentirsi sempre
nella dimensione in cui lui si sente bene,
gli dà la forza per sopravvivere
alle più grandi catastrofi.
Sicuramente la natura è tutt'oggi
la prima ad approfittare
della perfezione aurea delle distanze,
ma anche vari interpreti sublimi:
anche noi uomini apparteniamo alla natura.
Siamo stati in grado spesso,
forse anche inconsciamente,
di creare delle meraviglie,
interpreti sublimi di questo ϕ,
come per la piramide di Cheope,
il Partenone, il duomo di Milano,
la “Chaise Longue de Le Corbusier”,
la musica dei più grandi.
Finora abbiamo parlato
di sezione aurea nelle distanze,
ed effettivamente è una
delle cose che più sorprende.
Ma la proporzione aurea
c'è anche nei disegni vorticosi,
nei movimenti caotici,
nei disegni organici della natura.
Leonardo Fibonacci scoprì una proprietà
molto bella di una serie numerica,
una serie che si costruisce
sommando i due numeri che precedono:
55 è uguale a 34 più 21.
13 è uguale a 8 più 5 e così via.
Ma la cosa speciale
di questa serie numerica
è che per quanto avanti si vada
si troverà sempre
un nuovo numero, all'infinito,
che, se diviso per il precedente, da ϕ.
Provate.
34 diviso 21 fa ϕ.
21 diviso 13 fa ϕ.
Qualsiasi numero,
diviso per il precedente, dà ϕ.
Bello.
Ma dove sono i disegni
organici della natura?
Dove sono i moti vorticosi?
Dov'è il caos?
Provate a contare i petali dei fiori,
i rami di un albero,
le insenature di una costiera,
il proliferarsi dei conigli,
il numero delle spirali di una conchiglia,
i vortici di un uragano,
i disegni dentro i vostri occhi,
le “braccia” dei fiocchi di neve.
Sono sempre uno, due, tre,
cinque, otto, 13, 21, 34, 55, 89.
Non se ne scampa.
E, si potrebbe dire:
ne traiamo solo
un fiore di estrema bellezza
dal fatto che i petali
siano sempre in equilibrio.
Diversamente, però,
la potrebbe pensare un'ape
che, grazie a questa corolla,
trae nutrimento.
Se parlare della perfezione
tra la distanza degli occhi di una donna
e la sua bocca e il suo mento
potrebbe sembrarci,
quasi giustamente, una velleità,
altra gratitudine dovremmo riservare
a questo tendere verso la perfezione,
considerando che permette
lo sviluppo dei nostri embrioni,
oltretutto nati
con gli stessi moti vorticosi
delle più grandi galassie.
Innumerevoli altri sono i casi
che, se studiati,
portano a scoprire che
dietro alle cose più equilibrate,
quelle che non riusciamo
a spiegarci così immediatamente,
c'è un unico segreto
imperituro, ϕ: 1,618034.
Veramente, sono rari i casi
in cui non ci sia solo lui dietro.
Ma qual è il significato più sottile di ϕ?
Di cosa dovremmo essere capaci noi uomini,
se una lumaca è riuscita a sopravvivere,
grazie alla sua conchiglia, ai dinosauri?
I “Suchende”, siano loro
uomini di musica o  uomini di scienza,
tendono tutti a riconoscere
l'estrema potenza della correlazione
tra il grande e piccolo,
tra l'intero e le sue parti.
"Frattalico" dicono i matematici.
Ovvero, il tutto sta al grande
come il grande sta al piccolo.
Si riassume nei libri
di sezione aurea, tutto qui.
Ma se per il tutto,
a cui è chiaro che abbia contribuito
qualcuno di molto, infinitamente
molto più grande di noi,
la costruzione dell'equilibrio.
Per il grande, e per il piccolo,
dovremmo sentirci noi uomini
alla tastiera.
In una tastiera,
i tasti iniziano e i tasti finiscono.
Infinita è la musica
che su questi possiamo suonarci,
direbbe qualcuno.
E la lezione che io ho imparato -
dal mollusco, da “Le Corbusier”,
da un albero,
di fatto è questa:
scegliere una tastiera troppo grande,
dove non c'è musica
che noi sappiamo suonare,
è un alibi alla nostra inettitudine.
È un alibi a non dover intervenire
su noi stessi, sul mondo
e sui rapporti che tra noi
e il mondo intercorrono.
Se c'è dato disegnare una sedia,
ricordiamoci che potremmo farlo
come “Le Corbusier”.
Se c'è richiesto di disegnare,
o progettare, una pista ciclabile
facciamolo immaginandoci i nostri figli
pedalare lungo il suo percorso.
Se non possiamo intervenire sulle date
degli accordi del COP26,
chiediamoci se già noi, oggi,
stiamo prendendo, nel nostro campo,
la scelta più sostenibile.
Se ci è data la fortuna
di avere un bambino,
ricordiamoci di dedicargli il tempo
per imparare la vera gentilezza.
E se ci si è data la facoltà di votare,
ricordiamoci di non scegliere
chi sa imitarci
ma chi ha il coraggio di guidarci,
anche correndo il rischio di perderci.
In millenni di anni,
la matematica non ha fatto altro
che portare alla luce, per noi uomini,
frammenti di un unico segreto imperituro.
Per contribuire all'armonia,
alla rigenerazione, all'equilibrio
dobbiamo sentirci parte attiva
di questo interminabile spettacolo,
in cui il tutto cura il grande,
come il grande cura il piccolo.
Sarebbe d'accordo, penso, anche Siddharta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)